so welcome to circling late and some of
you may have already experienced
circling but for the ones that don't
this is an evening where we get the
opportunity to really be present with
what is and be in relationship with each
other and be curious about what that
what that means what that brings in us
as feelings thoughts and just be curious
about that experience and being real
with another human being so I'm gonna
invite you and we're gonna start with a
meditation short tuning in so get
yourself comfortable and let's close our
eyes and take a deep breath in and as
you breathe out feel the but your your
butt cheeks on the chair take another
deep breath in
just to notice your breath and notice
your body starting from your head all
the way down like shoulders to your
chest your belly to your legs to your
feet
I just know that and notice anything
that's present for you what does it mean
to be you in this moment what does it
mean to be with the people around you
and take another deep breath in
and when you're ready you can slowly
open your eyes and just let what's
outside come to you know efforting and
seeing and you can just go ahead and
look around make contact with other
people
and tonight we're going to circle and
focus all our intention to Preston here
is there anything that you want because
circling for you anything that's present
a lot present for me
that's been difficult trust that talking
to anybody's gonna help me so I've just
been on this path of learning to just
kind of be there for myself because I've
gone through this trial and error of
trusting so many different people that I
think I'm being conditioned to not trust
those who want to help me no I have
tenderness you say that
I'm I'm in this place in my life where I
just I'm having to make some pretty
concrete choices and and be okay with
whatever comes I mean I can only control
the way I react to the world and that's
been a big big thing for me recently but
I'm not sure my boundaries are with
other people with relationships with
what I deserve
I just know that I'm extremely
determined to do the right thing and to
just just to be loving just loving as I
possibly can without being needy or
clingy or unattractive or repulsive and
that's not even that I have a fear of
those things it's just I can't seem to
escape
failure tell me more about that you
can't skate failure failure
about what
I guess it's my own internal feelings
I've always desired to be trusted
loved seen and I guess right now my life
I don't really feel like there's really
anybody there for me the way I want them
to be there for me I know I can't blame
other people but that puts me in a place
of like alright well it's just me how do
I make myself feel good
be you're wanting to trust you one thing
to have people in your life and you
right now your experience is that you
don't you don't have people that you
feel that you can trust the way you want
to
I feel that I can I see it's even
interesting just sitting here and
circling and being in the presence of
all this it's like it's been a it's been
a journey of trust you know two years
ago I would have looked at something
like this and I think this is crazy
witchcraft hocus-pocus like why am I
talking to you yet Here I am hoping that
it
I learned something I get something
special out of it and I haven't felt
that way fully yet I feel like I am
learning but learning through struggle
and pain through disappointment and I'm
starting to question whether that's
healthy for me this joggling opinion
yeah you're experiencing it both yeah
I'm one on one hand the way I'm going
about it is I don't know if I'm trying
too hard to make other people happy or
be seen by other people there's
particular people in my life that I want
to be seen by people that I think love
me and tear nowhere in sight
when you said that you wanted to you
have people in your life you want to be
seen by eiffel like some ink
on the other on the other end I had
judged that part of me a girl I think
yeah Who am I to ask anything from
anybody like there's something special
about being self-sufficient and not
depending on other people or needing
anything from someone because I am the
creator of my reality yes it is special
yeah that's been I think it's a mixture
of exhaustion of wine to improve myself
and a little bit of pride for doing it
but I feel so lonely and confusing in
this you mean this process or this
journey to improve yourself this journey
yeah there's lots of ways to look at how
maybe I was happier before I got into
opening myself to spirituality and and
confronting my demons and my patterns
yeah I grew up I grew up with
financially stable family I had parents
that pretty much could afford to put me
in school I wanted to and I never really
experienced any problems with them when
I got into a relationship that they
didn't necessarily agree with that all
went away very quick and it was the
first time that I loved something but it
was judged as wrong and I didn't know
how to react to that and I feel like to
this day I'm still
still suffering from the from the not
being ready that impacts from my parents
even though I feel like I've apologized
a thousand times I've confessed my sins
a thousand times I've I feel
make a sense of protection like like I
wanted to make we know he can love who
we want to do and I feel also sadness
for
for that experience
what does it mean to you to be to trust
other people what does it look like what
does it feel like
there's a certain sense that I could be
myself it's that feeling of when you're
with you know you're with a friend or
Internet partner like you have to
contort yourself you have to walk on
eggshells and it won't be judged and it
won't triggering the other person it's
its freedom it's being alive joyful I
guess that is just just talking about it
and it's making me think that I I don't
really feel like I'm free to be myself
although all I'm doing is chasing the
very things that bring me to more
centered version of myself so it's it's
kind of exhausting
I'm still here
how how is your like how are you feeling
right now about about what happened with
your with with your family's reaction
not good because
there are things happening right now is
making me doubt ever resisting their
advice
like this coldness of like God took a
leap of faith or like believing in love
trusting that you know going after
something I thought he was inviting for
me and just supporting that feeling was
more righteous than anything my parents
could identifying me but after so much
so much curiosity so much wanted to grow
and learn and be seen to now feel like
there's no one there for me not even my
family that's brutal
so it's either I make a choice on my own
I agree with my family's judgments and I
know I don't have to but I know what
happens if you agree with you
it would just mean that everything I've
done so far was for nothing or at least
has a taste of that it makes me doubt
and goofy being something makes me down
in love and it reminds me of the time
where I thought that maybe I would just
be happy or dying alone because I didn't
feel understood growing up I had friends
compassionate people who liked me but I
never felt like I understood desired
into then just anything pretty picture
I'm hearing that it's really important
for you to have that in your life
your people in your corner who really
see you and
especially your family yeah
no that's feeling like my family does
see me I'm just not proud of how they go
about seeing me voice oh my god this
isn't who you are
no I Know Who I am
but then when I go about being a lot of
beans guess the results I'm going after
don't when you pan out so that's where
it gets confusing it's like well I chose
to you know deny with the two very
loving people who brought me into this
world sure they deny their advice and
start to create my own desires and
guidance and when that failed I just
found I put myself in this place like
but this
yeah I'm in the place right now I don't
think anybody understands it's really
going on with me is because I don't
really after everything that's happened
I don't really feel like I want that
there was a time when people had
compassion for me and led to more
confusion more judgment more pain
suffering how does it feel for you the
deep side is just in sired wanna know I
usually don't get tired I don't feel
like I'm not running a mile I'm not
jumping off a cliff every day it's like
it's funny I finally understand what a
heartbreak feels like I'm not sure not
want to I'm not sure I want to feel that
I guess I can see that what it teaches
us how do you understand
I used to find myself I was younger
thinking I'm so emotionally stable
there's nothing in this world that can
rock my my boat I'll always find
enjoying things always connect to people
I was always good with connecting people
on a social level so then when I saw
people like especially young men and
women struggling with internet
relationships or friendships or family
drama I used to laugh like that's like
get out of that like that's a waste of
time there's so many more important
things in the world the folks Val like
don't don't let your heart be broken
what are you immature I had a judgement
about that but now I'm in their position
and it humbles me so much and I'm just
seen here like wow like I'm almost not
proud I always see myself
I'm trying to find the empowering
meeting not at all
usually yeah I'm sorry but actually our
time but you just take a minute just
give us some bleep like what what's your
what you're getting about what he's
going through so far what I'm getting
about what you're going through is that
there is a way that you used to be in
this empowered place and this you had a
certain idea of your experience and now
it's a different kind of experience that
you used to see in other people and you
want to trust that and be trusted and
have how people see you for you want to
be yourself in this and also get some
meaning out of what you're going through
and I want to be seen through my actions
I want to be a an archetype or a shadow
or some kind of label that's predictable
thank you
we're beautiful
thank you you are too jealous to
continue where you left off would you
like a meditation to start I don't need
a meditation would you like to continue
where you left off everything I'm
talking abouts related to what I'm
talking about so I guess I continue
talking about what I was talking you
know yeah I felt so much power from you
and I felt a very complicated history
and present and it is
so
so
so it's this roughy rough feeling within
when you have when we have when we have
parents and relatives that have a
certain way and being that they want us
to be yeah
I almost feel some tiger or some lion
spirit within you bursting through that
into the world I'm happy to hear you
saying that because there is a lion and
a tiger and I don't think it's allowed
to be that out but man if it could I
think I would like to change the world
that I see Matt oh wow that's a great
question it's not that it's not allowed
that's my perception uh-huh it goes back
to my lack of trust and things I like to
think that the world is telling me the
right people are telling me that that
that energy is allowed but that energy
comes with some flaws and some rigidity
and that energy might step on some toes
I take some risks hmm especially the
toes of family yeah
earlier when you were bringing forth
this this vulnerability of talking to so
many people about how you felt and just
this desire to be gotten by people along
the way
and just not have been able to been
fully done or to have been you know in a
state of feeling like that you're able
to move forward as you're lying how's
that spirit without the rigidity that
what the stepping on the toes of family
along the way for me I felt a of like a
slow warm sensation through my through
my face where my eyes are and also
through my kind of main my heart and my
chest because I've really really felt so
close to you at that moment and when we
were discussing all the things that are
leading up to where you're at right now
and just the breakthrough I just it just
all feels so close I feel so real feel
so raw does what what you were and then
you brought up love as well in this what
where where does that the rest what does
that feel like love is that love for
family love for partner love for what
where what is that love love for all but
to be more specific because I do feel
like this this rising of a moment of
being more specific and what's going on
with me is is love with intimate
partners
growing up I I would say that I was a
nice guy
and that being nice didn't serve me made
sense of like those metaphors like nice
guys finish last and I was always so
confused cuz I was always told I was
handsome and charming still are yeah
yeah but uh never really resulted in the
relationships I wanted to create and
that was annoying but you know now I'm
reading her book called no more mr. nice
guy and I actually feel like I've I've
mastered a lot of what's in that book
but the circumstances that I've chosen
to be in are challenging more than I
could ever possibly imagine and I think
I'm aware of that choice that I'm making
there sometimes I wake up and I go what
am i doing this
but it's I've already passed like the
checkpoint like why do you being with me
inside okay like having a conversation
my old friends like where do they just
like flabbergasted when they hear me
talk mmm the guy practically cochon
their friends because of everything I've
been through mm-hmm would you ask me
about love and for me it's reconnecting
to that feeling that I felt when I met
my soul mate yeah you know or like when
you not in to make it separate from I
feel just like when that feeling when
like you're really excited and you
really feel like someone gets you mmm
that's like the best feeling in the
world
and right now I feel like I've lost that
and I've been in acceptance of that for
so long and I want to pause and see this
lost feeling of being gotten that
through for me that sends a kind of like
a pulse of unknowingness through me and
it makes me like to seek knowing this
within me so what as as you're going
through the this this
love and gotten Asst that are missing is
this related with family with the
soulmate where where where's like the
where's the epicenter of so may the soul
mate and with that with that the first
moments of the of the love when it was
when you felt the rebirth of the
soulmate connection what does that be
like euphoric peaceful
boundless
epic joyful as you say all these words I
just I feel like the best feeling in the
world just feels so good
boundless Wow
before such good and and and then this
these these these feelings what what was
the what was this the causes that led to
not feeling that there was an effect of
family as well of the of this you were
going on a path that was the family was
like this is not a normal path that
we're used to yeah and that also
affected the soul mate the relationship
yes was there was there what was the
feeling towards the towards the families
effect on the relationship shock
surprise
I I wasn't ready for it I think that was
the biggest issue of it happening then
what was it their effect on it as well
it's not only the fact they initially
received from it but their effect on it
it was traumatic it was destructive at
least that's how it seemed and I was in
it
no know what to do with it
and that that that hindered the lion
well no I'm not really sure when I
entered the line yet Susu loses it so
there's now there's this exploration of
what is hindering the lion I mean I can
break it down as simple as fear of what
a rejection from anyone family loved
ones friends uh-huh earlier when you
were discussing this French these
friendships that you have where you are
now
Preston Curley that is able to coach his
friends with his life experience and
help them then you were talking about it
in a way that was that I would be like
if I was your mom or dad or grandparent
or cousin I would be hella proud to hear
that mmm I'm so proud it's a combination
of things it's a combination of pride
from them and also thinking that I'm
very washed
thinking that I'm being manipulated so
then there's a fear of their disapproval
familial disapproval yeah of course in
then but I what's important that comes
up for me as you say that is I I embrace
that disapproval I I said this is this
is what I'm choosing to do at first I
wasn't sure
more like shaky on the fence about my
Jess's but then I realized how important
it was for me to honor what it is that
I'm going for ha yeah it Stella tell us
about what the feeling is like when
there's a lot of forces giving doubt and
fear and then for you to hone in on a
true path forward hmm well what's making
things difficult is not seeing things
come together taking up half I mean it
feels good to have like this is my
choice I'm trusting this regardless of
the outcome regardless of what happens
I'm letting go of certain safeties and
letting go of certain people because I
believe that this is the right thing for
me to do and well that feels good it
actually it feel very empowered it's
good to know that I can do that mm-hmm
it is a bit scary to have that not be
seen by anyone
yes and now that that that brings me to
a feeling of of tribal importance so I
need to be seen by my tribe ask somebody
that is making great progress in
different ways in order for me to really
feel actualized and the who are the
people that are being like put to the
side as you move forward on this true
path what if who are those almost
everyone who's everyone
family old friends people who supported
me in the past unconditionally they
supported me I guess you could say I
look like somebody who's just lost in
love mmm but that's my choice mm-hmm
so I'm taking a leap of faith because I
can't have an outcome I can't control
how another person behaves yeah but I
can be honest and truth is that I know
that I'm doing this from a good place
yeah and that that leap of faith how
does it make you feel what is a call
from within what runs up the leap of
faith is surprising because I'm
surprised I'm doing any of this I'm
surprised that I'm involved in so many
different communities and moving my body
in ways that I never did talking to
people that I would have judged before
openly honorably so it feels good to
like know like oh you did that you did
it it's gone I mean there's that
is there a part of the the lion that is
now coming from walking down this troop
path that is shining more so that the
lion is also able to do alignment with
the soul mate as well I'm the only one
who sees it I am feeling it with you
right now not directly there with you on
a daily basis but I'm feeling it with
you right now
and it feels really good I feel like I'm
just scratching the surface but that I'm
with you
and that
who you are and where you're coming from
and what you're doing is so important to
appreciate that
I feel really that feels kinda
and there's so much more to do always
been always more yeah you're amazing
thank you you're also amazing mmm love
you love you too bro
oh damn that was such a tough place to
end all right the output that's what you
get for 20 minutes Urkel ha ha ha yeah
yeah we got a look that means there's
more doubt all right ready first look at
that
overall things I've noticed about you
okay there's this gentleness that you
bring to a circle into somebody that
probably is good either whether you
think about it or not there's also a
playfulness that disarms people and yet
there's a confidence there's like a it's
almost like a it's a playful confidence
I noticed to me you seem to have really
great instincts including including what
I think is really important and some
people this is what I would call it
nobody's noticing the obvious first
don't disregard the obvious I go to
what's right there speak to it you know
where is the question of that or
something like that well it's important
great description and meditate a great
description of circling and the
meditation I'm gonna tell you story with
you shared where is that charts started
leaving with impact that you feel
tenderness it's difficult difficulty to
trust
and there was where I wanted a little
bit more in the beginning after that was
some paraphrasing you'll catch up the
fun stuff but because he covered a lot
of content maybe any difficulty to trust
talking difficult in trust talking with
anyone better to actually help not sure
there's boundaries or even what he
deserves
and it's determined to do it right but
you can't escape failure I mean that's a
lot of [ __ ] right there
yeah so that that would be that would
warrant some paraphrasing and like
living in Peter back what he just said
because it was powerful right and
because at that moment you said tell me
more which was great but you also need
to catch up with what was already set
first yeah and then let's see
you did you did paraphrase a little bit
after that that was it was funny so you
talked about you heard him like wanting
to be seen and felt the ache in your
heart I thought that was really good so
you're you're you're a great sharing of
impact that me pretty much did
consistently so you're kind of getting
that down already a really good
questions very profound questions so
they think the thing I was wanting more
of was getting what he was feeling which
you could either do through powerful any
what he would already shared because he
was pretty he was laying out where he
was feeling like right in front of us
and he was very open about that in touch
with it I said we could just just power
for this Apple you can also feel it a
little bit sure what else we came in
about yeah I realized that wouldn't want
it to do that more when you invited me
to do that the end yeah oh yes
and they were something like I had a
curiosity but like when you talked about
he loves something but his parents
disagreed and it's been some time like
confessing his sins not free to be
himself and I like that you kind of got
that and he said yeah I felt protective
I'd like like like I want you to be able
to love whoever you want and they're
like to me that was like grasping the
obvious and like stating it because I
could have been missed
it wasn't exactly that obvious there was
some that he was catching it a little
bit and then you asked what happens and
what happens if you agree if you agreed
with your family's judgments that was
written consent Jesus had a lot more
after that anything actually let me take
you first man yeah I asked you guys for
you cuz also did a great job
yeah I'm getting so close that's life
yeah somebody to Christ
so Alan the the words that came to me
for you you're extremely validating just
like I'm validating human being and a
lot of positivity it's almost like
you're come from like this yeah positive
your life where it could be or something
yeah it's like and it's a way that you
love and you also I don't know how to
describe despite a good picture of like
you love but you also have a sword in
your hand
like a slice right through to the truth
you yeah it's like it's like you're your
the person who will say anything that
other people won't have the courage to
say or ask thank you for that yeah yeah
that feels so real with me I mean when
you said that I just burst Oh laughs
they're so hard and uncontrollably yeah
Wow
yeah in the the sword is meant for truth
to go where others won't wander that I
that we will wander down that path
together arm in arm loving and caring
together yeah let's get there yeah I
love that you started out and president
saying that you felt like you felt both
his power and his complicated history he
talked about the like the lion and the
tiger when you then he started there I
had a little bit of a twinge yeah like
it's almost seemed like a leap or a jump
ahead of where he was at because he was
it's in my standpoint he was in a lot of
pain he talks about how sure
this whole thing has been and he's it's
like everything he said was like what's
kind of a present thing like that the
awful lost feeling of like what to do
and like I yeah I don't have a choice
because like this is me and I've made my
choice and you know I'm suffering
because of it and you know and and and
you went to the lion attack but yet
somehow that leap worked
it's like it brought out a little bit of
that part of him so that's where it's
like just kind of trust your instincts
like there's no wrong place to turn I
also wanted to recognize that that
they're not gonna come back to it again
to it but like there's a part that got
like maybe like you haven't Chrissa the
positivity you have a tendency to like
go to like okay where's where's the
lemonade in this right and yet he was
he's still feeling like a lemon has left
he's not even getting the company in
that you're really identifying what was
so correct in my positivity that I
you're identifying me correctly with
that positive remark because that is yes
that is part of the lion and tiger call
but it's also because that's how I felt
from the from the start with identifying
complexity and a power at the same time
and then I just to follow up here by by
like you said there's there's almost
there's a it's so interesting how
different these different tech these
different ways of approaching a circle
can can work but in the way that you
were talking about the lemon there's
almost a I would like to know also how
to walk down that path better about the
lemon and what would be the right ways
to approach the lemon path and then get
to the lemonade as well yeah yeah so
yeah so like you're recognizing there's
this liar and a tiger in him and that's
nothing wrong with saying that and but I
think from most of the circle you sort
of stayed on that side of it mmm-hmm so
let me just kind of go through the rest
and I'll come back to that but you did
you touched on things for him which I
thought were important like he's talking
about I'm not wanting to step on toes
and you know especially your families
right yeah yeah and I love to asking you
I loved you asking him like a family's
love and I poured out like the first
time with his soulmate and then you were
reflecting like those feelings back to
him like the boundlessness and some of
the other things he said epic did you
ask about that and then you asked about
his parents effect on that so that was
starting to come back to what was there
it's a little bit of lemon a little bit
yeah and he said it was traumatic and so
and then after he said it was traumatic
you went so that hindered the lion ah
sounds like good yeah what about the
germ and what about the trauma
yeah that's a big word is trauma
zatoichi trauma sec whoa so so that's so
like the trauma is still you know with
it you're still suffering i like let's
be with that let's be with that yeah and
he even talked about how he got he's
basically he's got he's been abandoned
by his family and abandoned by his
friends for choosing love i mean that's
like that's [ __ ] up
yeah and so like let's speak with that
[ __ ] up this he's been so he's been
alone in that like he said maybe one
person with him in that to himself and
then but you kind of talk about being
empowered and you said and that's not
not see all right he said it's not seen
by anyone and yes like but not seem like
by anyone or yeah and he said who's
anyone I thought that was really good
like I was imagining it was he still
talking about Paris but that's when it
came out like no it's everybody it's
like it's friends everybody in her life
there's also some coaching going I
thought the friends that they're still
like boom like wow right yeah so I think
I think what what were you got with him
was leaking like I think he felt loved
and cared for and appreciated by you and
you brought out that lion possibility in
him and he sort of did validate where is
that the one thing I think I wanted I
would have wanted more of this is to be
with like for me but what I'm left with
it's like here's the sense I have like
you're you're grieving the loss of your
family and the loss of your friends
[Music]
and I'm you're wishing that wasn't true
like you're wishing they would get she
like she they would support you yeah
also I'm also grieving the loss of love
too yeah yeah which love their luck yeah
yeah
intimate motive as well like all is this
all had an impact on everything this my
whole chain that makes sense
the intimate love are you talking about
Elena's yeah so it's it's so in other
words you're its effect it's damaged
it's dams even of that yeah yeah that's
I think it was yeah it like sprint yeah
so this has been like yeah yeah look
what you did a good job is like what's
been created out of that is like through
that suffering is like wanting to grow
on a level that most people don't even
know about the whole personal growth
development thing like people get a job
people work out on their bodies they eat
healthy may find them happy
whereas like me and like no I'm gonna go
directly to the soul cuz that's where
like nothing made sense to me it wasn't
practical I'm getting also is that
you're tired yeah yeah oh yeah so I mean
I like you gotta you know you got a
circle the way that sees you as well
I would just offer an alternate
possibility of like practicing like
being what's with what's most sure right
now mmm-hmm like the line was there but
most was most present was his suffering
the lemon the trauma leather
I once we get something like the bottom
of that that's the air my god alright so
anymore that has something presents no
like okay that's what's there and that
might be it
and that mean that might take the whole
time or if it doesn't you say alright
alright so we're here what does it look
like from here that's it and then and
then you see if he goes there yeah like
what so what what now
whoa no yeah this may be part of my
positivity also is a somewhat analogous
to coaching as well rather than rather
than circling yeah tiny elements of tiny
element yeah and what's this coming
coming from love and care it's your hand
yeah yeah it's also its if you're not
you're not completely in the full
connection of where you could be yeah
yeah we're actually we're here is it
because the lemons are really important
absolutely really important but I do
think society spends way too much time
on lemons and way too little time
so--that's but i also think at the same
time to say doesn't spend enough time on
the lemons as well i also think that is
true at the same time but I think the
panic that you've spent enough time on
in earlier way they spend time
intellectualizing and I'm complaining
about it what actually feeling it mostly
resisting it yeah
yeah and avoiding it yeah yeah exactly
there's better ways before lemon and
then there's also hopefully not getting
stuck in lemon that's kind of why I
guess it's almost a fear for someone
else to be stuck in lemon when I was
invited to be with the uncomfortable
like the line and to be with what's
uncomfortable and what feels hard it's
unpleasant in the moment but it's so
freeing right over the hump yeah and I
think a lot of people don't think the
time to sit enough in it to go over also
he was another analysis cuz you're right
I also think
here's another analysis person can you
can you can correct me how how you how
you actually feel about this but this is
how I felt I felt that by your initial
story and explanation of how you had not
gotten felt you had not been you enough
felt like you were gotten by so many of
the people that you had talked to
to me that meant that you had already
went through the process of lemony and
lemony and lemony I might be completely
wrong but I felt like it was time for
lemonade you know what what wasn't
probably clear is what happened was a
lot of these people I actually did
perceive that they understood me like
therapists coaches healers magic people
whatever you want to call them Wizards
Doctor Strange like I've talked with a
lot of people in the spiritual coaching
realm looking for guidance on these
topics and a lot of them did validate
like no you're doing fine but you need
to do is blah blah blah none of them
ever said told me to sit with this they
always validate it like no like your
instincts are correct like this
shouldn't be happening to you like
you're a victim of this they never said
the word victim but that was the energy
those transpired so I guess the
importance of like if we're to tie this
all together the importance of having me
sit with that trauma and then the lemon
I guess that would have been the impact
of doing that because most of the time I
was either coached out of it or told
that like not like this is like you
shouldn't be going through this so you
would say then you have yet to fully sit
and be with the lemon and then how other
people sit with the lemon with you to
help you feel like they're getting
you're like I don't feel like that part
has been seen there has been seeing yeah
yeah
by yourself sort of yeah been in it too
with someone exactly and that's where
the trust thing comes come back to trust
me because the guy wouldn't trust
someone I feel like people would just
sit in it just because they're doing it
but like to actually understand like
what is going on that's like the
challenge yeah
because what I'm doing right now they'll
kind of they start to become complex
after what is employable when they're
suffering in any way they're resisting
where they're at and they're trying to
do anything they possibly can to be
somewhere else yeah
and so like the the possibility being
somewhere else is seducing yeah but it's
hard to get somewhere else when you when
you're not fully present or when you
actually are because it keeps calling
you back it's like this isn't this isn't
resolved yet this isn't healed Oh
aka the reason why the conversation
about lemons even comes up is because it
hasn't been fully acknowledged and
gotten otherwise the conversation about
lemons usually doesn't come up it's not
because it was already yeah exactly
yeah so so the concept of being with
somebody where there's that where
they're at not only not only do you
create a bond of intimacy and
understanding but they also actually get
to feel safe they have company and they
can start to make sense of it at all I'm
not crazy for feeling this way I think
this way and now they can actually sink
into that relax into their actual
experience even though it's been
suffering
yeah comforter and they make sense of it
now they feel it all the way fully they
let go over the resistance and somewhat
taken so much energy kiss to reside
resistant just survive it and fine it
off right and now they don't have to do
any of that huh now like they can expand
more fully into themselves and then they
get to the bottom of it and usually
somewhere around there or even below it
it's like their own wisdom mm-hmm like
this is my next step and they access it
themself in a way that they couldn't
possibly by somebody telling them this
is what ya could do or whatever they
have they have to finish what they
started I think yes called all that all
those life lessons to them for a reason
and to like they discover the fullness
of that reason they're just gonna keep
recreating it and then sometimes in
order for them to get almost all the
time I guess in order for people to get
to the point of unlocking that very
bottom dwelling wisdom is the
requirement of another human being to
actually get the trauma to get the
lemons to be there with them with the
feeling without trying to fix them I
would say that's not always the case but
if it's still there and we're in
relationship then right now it's
probably the case all probably a lot of
people mostly look more relational
creatures oh yeah probably usually the
case yeah exactly yeah yeah that was
really well put Bob that's a really good
way to I think close out what what just
happened with the lemons that was really
good
I appreciate I I can't I almost can't
get over the difference between circling
and coaching I can get over thinking
about it because it's so fascinating
almost everybody only coaches and then
um even then almost nobody coaches and
then out of a few people that do coach
the only couple percent of people that
do coaching on how to coach us probably
of that same amount of percentage
circles or like just gets people rather
than tries to push them in the direction
of poaching so then there's that
mindfuck that exists and then if people
actually got to the feeling of being
done and sat with the lemons with other
people then they could get that wisdom
to come true from within themselves and
then to move on and make it easier to
yeah and there is an aspect in the later
stages that you get to in a circle once
he sort of got down to the bottom of
something we call that deep-sea diver
and the first is something new but my
wife but in that in the getting there to
the bottom of something there is a place
where quote some sort of coaching could
happen but usually what happens is it
arises organically as we're creating it
together it's not like I'm the coach and
I said okay you need to have this
experience so you can heal so I'm going
to guide you through it because again I
have the wisdom so it's like same thing
is advice right versus it's coming from
our Co exploration Wow it seems like
almost this wants to happen a woman but
you know what do you think yeah and
that's again and it's coming from the
joint wisdom and and his wisdom and
that's powerful yeah you know
transformation happens also and so good
it's just not through the forcing of
fixing that happens in routine it comes
from the g1/s something yeah from being
but what he want isn't just kind of
letting it take a different shape
okay good job guys
did you uh pass yeah